the United States Secret Service is a
federal law enforcement agency under the
Department of Homeland Security they are
charged with conducting criminal
investigations and protecting the
nation's leaders in their families in
1865 the Secret Service was first
established with the reported 1/3 of the
currency in circulation being
counterfeit at the time the Secret
Service was created to suppress
counterfeit currency it was commissioned
in Washington DC as the Secret Service
Division of the Department of the
Treasury after the assassination of
President William McKinley in 1901
Congress and formally requested that the
Secret Service provide presidential
protection a year later the Secret
Service assumed full-time responsibility
for presidential protection the Secret
Service is mandated by Congress were two
distinct and critical national security
missions protecting the nation's leaders
and safeguarding the financial and
critical infrastructure of the United
States acceptance into the Secret
Service is highly restrictive and 2011
the service accepted listen 1% of his
15,600 special agent applicants after
the reactivation of team rainbow 2015
one Operator was recruited to bring his
skills and expertise to assist in the
fight against terrorism on a global
scale this operator was named warden
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
: McKinley codenamed worden as a
defending operator and team rainbow at
the age of 18 warden enrolled in the
Marine Corps while they're here in
various commendations tutor was
aggressive quick thinking and his
ability to protect potential problems in
the future and how to overcome them
eventually these personal qualities
helped them to achieve master sergeant
despite several minor infractions on his
record growing up he often butted heads
with his father who was a strict and
domineering individual he took his role
as a protector very seriously and
repeatedly found himself caught in
situations whether at home or in school
defending his younger brothers and this
trait was only further enhanced and more
deeply ingrained into his nature during
his time with the Marines not long after
his third tour ended he left and entered
the Secret Service specializing in the
close protection detail of Baldwin the
Secretary of State warden's incredible
skill set came to light when the US
diplomatic junket was attacked by
insurgents and his quick-thinking was
instrumental in saving Baldwin during
the assault the attackers used a number
of smoke grenades flash banks and heavy
suppressive fire to separate the
Secretary of State from the rest of his
protection detail when McKinley realized
that all of their evacuation routes have
been compromised as off-the-cuff
attitude along with the help of the
specialized glasses mended he alone was
able to evacuate Bolton eventually
Baldwin went on to win the US
presidential and requested warden he
assigned to the presidential protective
division from here woody spit over a
decade in Washington protecting
important political figures often with
notoriety comes a certain amount of
power and in his case this influence
meant access to a number of inner
circles their secrets and being the
go-to guy and handling delicate
situations and before long warden had
amassed quite a war chest of political
favors wily has managed to dazzle a
number of high-ranking individuals
he's also collected a number of enemies
including politicians businessmen and
lobbyists fortunately for him and
unfortunately for them he is a walking
encyclopedia filled with all of their
dirty little secrets and he's clever
enough to leave people on the right
track but smart enough not to implicate
himself in the process
he is incredibly adept at manipulating
others from deepening his Kentucky drawl
when conversing with Republican senators
- portraying the perfect southern
gentlemen around woman and his
reputation as a ladies man often
precedes him being the foremost expert
in clothes protection detail with
president Baldwin finishing a second
term
warden received high endorsements and
swiftly completed his transition into
rainbow while it's clear he adores his
team and works well with others in his
environment his connection to the Oval
Office seems to have permanently
installed him with a sense of
immortality that may prove fatal
warden utilizes a gadget called the
glance with these smart glasses wooden
can see through smoke and turn around
what could be a local Intel situation
activating the glance can also prevent
warden from being blinded by flash fix
or cleans an existing flash blindness
status however glances thermal vision
only works as long as warden is able to
stay on mobile like nook warden is just
another single operator who comes from
his own organization in this case the
Secret Service I've had a lot of
requests to combine a number of these
solo operators into single videos which
is fear but for my own enjoyment and yes
believe it or not this is why I research
and create videos for YouTube I like to
create these based on the organisation
itself rather than the operators the
small blurb at the start of these videos
really helps me to immerse into the
story of each specialist otherwise thank
you very much for watching and I'll
catch you in the next one Cheers
[Music]